جورجيا اخواتي
لكن اريد ان اقوله عندما نقول عن اردوغان
بانهولوس
كما تعرفون
هناك سيكون القمه الثلاثيه بحضور الرئيس
التركي والرئيس الايراني في السياسه لا
عدو دائم ولا صديق دائم انها حرب المصالح
يا ساده حين فرقتهم الحرب جمعتهم المصالح
السوريون والاتراك وعقد من المعارك
والحروب ضربات لا تتوقف والهجمات متواصله
انقره تقصف جوا ودمشق ترد على الارض اما
انا لهذه الحرب ان تتوقف سؤال يطرحه
القاسي والداني على هذه المعموره لكن هل
سيجيب البلدان عنه اردوغان يتخلى عن غروره
والسوريه جثه لا تضرها طعنه اخرى والصلح
خير فهل حان وقت التصالح هؤلاء عن مفارم
اللحوم السوريه نتحدث وللقصه بقيه الجمر
يغلي ونيران الحرب لا تنتهي
[موسيقى]
على الاراضي السوريه ودمشق تستقبل ضربات
الكيان الجويه باحضان مفتوحه فما عاد
لديها ما تقاوم به جوعها حتى تجد ما تصد
به غارات الطائرات
الاقدار قال لنا ان تخيل العواقب الوخيمه
لهذه الحرب السوريه وبعد 12 عاما من
الاقتتال الداخلي والضربات الخارجيه هناك
اكثر من خمسه ملايين طفل بحاجه الى
المساعده داخل سوريا كثير من الاطفال
ولدوا في الحرب وكثيرون منهم لا يعرفون
الا الحرب قتل منهم حوالي 900 طفل في عام
2018 وحده هذا الصراع الدائر في سوريا منذ
عام 2011 اسفر عن وقوع خسائر فادحه في
الشعب السوري حيث قتل اكثر من اربع مئه
الف شخص واضطر اكثر من نصف السكان الى
مغادره منازلهم في اكبر
للاجئين منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه حرب
احرقت الشجر وقتلت البشر وحطمت الحجر نعم
حتى الاثر السوريه لم يعد لها وجود بين
مدمره ومسروقه ومنهوبه ومبيوعه للخارج
ليدخل العام 2023 بعد حرب مدمره في سوريا
ويحيل البلد السوري الى وطن يستحيل العيش
فيه فمع كل ذلك لم يبقى اقتصاد للسوريين
ليتكئوا عليه الدولار الامريكي الواحد
باتا يعادل اليوم اكثر من
7300 ليره سوريه لقد استحالت سوريا الى
الخراب عن بكره ابيها على الرغم من كل تلك
الالاعيب تجد سوريا نفسها تغرق اليوم في
الجوع والبرد والفقر في ازمه اقتصاديه لم
تشهد لها مثيلا تشكر الازمه الرهينه اكبر
خطر على البلد في حدوده الراهنه منذ اتفاق
تصالح المصالح بعد قطيعه دامت لاكثر من
احد عشر عاما بوادر التقارب تلوح في الافق
بين سوريا وتركيا انقره كانت من اوائل من
استغلوا الفوضى السوريه لتنقضى على
اهدافها في الشمال السوري من جهه ونقصد
هنا الاكراد بينما دعم الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان المعارضه السوريه في مواجهه
النظام السوري بقياده بشار الاسد لكن ما
بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه ليس كما قبلها ادرك
اردوغان انه يجب عليه حل القضيه مع سوريا
على طاوله الحوار لا على ارض المعارك وفي
الحقيقه اردوغان ربما عرف ذلك بعد فوات
الاوان فالانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه على
بعد اشهر قليله والداخل التركي يغلي بعد
ان انهكت المعارك السوريه
الوطني واردوغن يبحث عن نصر من انتخابي
قبل خوض الاقتراع هنا وللمره الاولى منذ
بدايه المعارك وزراء الدفاع ورؤساء
الاستخبارات في اجتماع ثلاثي بين موسكو
وانقر ودمشق على الاراضي الروسيه من اجل
التصالح وما كان مستحيلا اصبح واقعا وبعد
سنوات من الجمود السياسي الذي وصل الى حد
العداء بين سوريا وتركيا ها هي العلاقات
بين البلدين في الايام الاخيره تعيش نوعا
من الدفء يمكن ان يقود في المستقبل القريب
الى لقاء تاريخي بين الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ونظيره السوري بشار الاسد لكن
هل يترك اردوغان حلفائه في المعارضه
السوريه لقد جمعتهم الحرب ليقترب الصلح من
تفريقهم هذه المعارضه والثوار في سوريا
وهؤلاء الموالون لنظام بشار الاسد تفرقوا
في الحرب
النوم اليوم يجتمعون ضد الصلح بين اردوغان
والاسد وخرجت المظاهرات في عموم البلاد
لتردد المعارضه بمخالفه اردوغان لوعوده
معهم اردوغان بهذا الصلح يريد اعاده حوالي
اربعه ملايين لاجئ سوري من بلاده الى
وطنهم ويهدف الى السيطره على منطقه امنه
بانق ثلاثين كيلومترا داخل الاراضي
السوريه وبشار الاسد يطلب رحيلا كاملا
للقوات التركيه من بلده او قد يقبل برحيل
جزئي ايضا لكن الولايات المتحده لا تريد
صلح وهو المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
يقول نحن لا ندعم الدول التي تعزز
علاقاتها او تعرب عن دعمها لاعاده
الاعتبار لبشار الاسد الديكتاتور الوحشي
بعد جحيم اكثر من عقد من الزمن تتجه سوريا
نحو الصلح مع تركيا مع رفض امريكي قاطعا
لهذه المصالحه برايكم هل يتجاهل الطرفان
الولايات المتحده ويعقدان صلحا تاريخيا
برعايه روسيه وهل ستنعم سوريا ولو بقليل
من الهدوء بعد كل هذا
[موسيقى]